talking all sequels much excitement when
maybe is it true Bill and Ted three
[Applause]
pegged alive I heard this is the thing
didn't having you talked about this yeah
yeah the writers had a story and we're
trying to make it yeah so what where our
buildings had not sympathy well in the
50s yeah yeah we'd be building telling
their fifties I think that just makes me
laugh right there but what happened to
be but there's a cool story basically
they're supposed to write a song to save
the world and they haven't done that so
the pressure of having to save the world
you know their marriages are falling
apart their kids are kind of mad at them
and and but then someone comes from the
future and tells them if they don't
write the songs just out the world now
it's the universe and so they have to
save the universe because the you know
time is breaking apart and so the
elements of the past are situated to the
that person from the Puritans me yeah
I'm so lucky to see village a three and
you are in it
ya can't get in a movie without you know
okay you find someone's globe on I'll
come in here Karthik ie
exactly if you're ever in a bar and a
guitar song comes in do people just look
at you carvaka is going to he's going
yeah yeah which is kind of cool in way
that it's still alive so could you say
accident then yeah yeah that okay yeah
what yeah
okay I'm gonna use this like I'm
training
[Applause]
[Music]